sébastien richard est une victime des
frères de sainte croix et le porte
parole de leur recours collectif pour
gaston dumas 82 ans
le prédateur c'était un enseignant des
clercs de saint viateur dans les années
50 ils ont visionné le film français
grâce à dieu parce que vous voulez
porter plainte contre bernard preneur je
supporte occultes qui relate le combat
des victimes de sévices sexuels et même
de viol d'un prêtre pédophile de lyon
que les évêque du diocèse dont le
cardinal philippe barbarin ont protégé
le fait leur reflète assez fidèlement ce
qui s'est passé dans ma vie suite à ces
évènements lors gaston s'est reconnu
dans un des personnages emmanuel
épileptique dont la vie a été
littéralement détruite par le prêtre
prédateur mais je veux faire quelque
chose de ta vie jusqu'au mans c'est ça
ma vie toi
la parole libérée c'est ça ma vie je
comprends rien fait
à 15 ans j'ai laissé l'école parce que
je te donne un peu caractériel était
frustré j'ai été complètement démolies
alors l'école ça m'intéressait plus mais
aujourd'hui encore je suis des séquelles
de sault une agression sexuelle sur un
enfant c'est l'assassinât d'un homme
seul sébastien se retrouve dans le
personnage d'alexandre qui aidé par sa
famille et le premier a entamé des
démarches contre le prêtre et
l'archevêché
vous avez une idée d'autres victimes qui
pourraient témoigner mais je suis sûr
qu'il en existe les victimes de lyon ils
sont une centaine se sont rencontrés
organisés ont créé le site web la parole
libérée et ils ont poursuivi non
seulement le prêtre pédophile mais aussi
le cardinal barbarin pour non
dénonciation de crime pédophile
ils ont gagné en première instance je ne
vous raconte pas le nombre de gens qui
m'ont dit parce que je vous ai entendu
j'ai testé pas mal vu la vie parce que
vous avez entendu je lui ai demandé de
l'aide ou avait failli passe aux gestes
moins 20 des jeunes tous les jeunes qui
vivent des choses comme ça de sortir les
personnes âgées qui ont vécu ce que moi
j'ai vécu qui on garde ce soit caché sa
pts et ça sorte et ça va vous aidez moi
la seule chose que j'ai envie de dire à
des gens qui penseraient à ça c'est
penser à ceux qui vous aiment
pourquoi tu peux tout seul devant
pour que ce que j'ai subi se reproduise
plus
[Musique]
et puis pour vous
si vous avez quelque chose nous sommes
donc il faut pas avoir peur de parler
est ce que au québec
nos évêques ont caché des choses comme
ça est-ce qu'ils ont protégé cpdp là je
pense que la mère façon pendant savoir
se fait d'avoir un enquête publique
le dernier mot reste celui du personnage
de françois dans le film le plus radical
de tous geithner françois de vous dans
la vraie vie que nous avions rencontré à
lyon on a été pris comme ça dans un
tourbillon et et peut-être que ce film
c'est l'apogée du tourbillon
je pense que ça va avoir un impact non
négligeable que je sais c'est une pierre
monumentale qui ont la possibilité
d'aller voir le film qu'ils arrivent ils
ça va les aider à comprendre bien des
choses
ce qui est important de comprendre c'est
que lorsqu'il ya des coups médiatiques
de cette importance là leur portage
qu'on fasse moment plus le film il ya
des gens qui vont rappliquer vont nommer
devons demander de l'aide
faut être prêt jean michel leprince sera
du canada montréal